[Music]
the suit the suit he
the statistic
that the game is supposed to be managed
with the statistic that one can download
from fifa now the 2020 law is about to come out
my son wants to buy 2020
I don't know what new things it brings  And well,
each of the movements that are made are
based on statistics, so that's
why it's fun to look a little bit at a
group of data that is large, there are not
a lot of inconveniences of
large groups, now the
clustering part that I want  tell how it is
a tutorial is about it we are going to use
a little two-dimensional data
we are going to say when a method
can work or not I am going to
pass this on because it is a little bit that I am going
to give a talk that is a lot
longer than the minutes I have now so
I'm going to work with how
class works what how clusterin should work
what is unsupervised learning and
that is based on the fact that you have
elements that you have to  know very well
a database that you have to know and one
intends after applying the methods to
have an output of a division a
partition of the data that I enter that
has a certain coherence then the
definition of cluster that is a
very lax problem badly conditioned we say
mathematicians is why
we don't know what we want, that is, we
don't have a perfect ultimate as in
classification we have a partition
that is the exact one and one wants to find
a rule that returns that partition and
generalizes here one has to give a
partition that looks like  reasonable then
the reasonable partition is the partition
that puts labels on groups that has
cohesion towards minimizing the distances
within a group and separates the
groups the partition says that groups are
different if they are so far apart from
each other that is what one would want
happened then when one has a
data set with those
two-dimensional characteristics on top one can see one
only that there are groups then you
would like the automatic method to generate
labels for those groups now when
you have something
like that I create it so with four groups
it is not so easy to distinguish what
those groups
are those are Gaussians that have  different
dimension in the variance
covariance matrix therefore they are and on top of that they
are close to each other so
this is a difficult data set even in two
dimensions
for many methods therefore the
methods each method is like it is set up
to distinguish data from one
a certain type and then there is the fifa that
nobody knows what it has inside or how it
has it inside, so the visualization
of that amount of data is another
problem, but we are going to start
with these that are two-dimensional
and that allow me to say at least the
three methods that I am going to put in the fifa
at least I want to see how they
work so these data have
a clear structure and it is not the
structure  Flower petal flower structure
that I recently did with four causes
These data also present problems
when it comes to finding a method that
distinguishes these two classes, then
container clustering and the most
used clustering methods work by
maximizing distances
between groups between objects of different
groups of clusters and minimizing
within each one of the clusters
I cannot go there but I am not
showing the structure of what averages is going to
do here because because here
averages is going to look at that of maximizing
differences and concentrating what it is going to do
taking  the means of each group and the
mean of the entire group in the
mean of the entire group will have the
total mean and you will see the difference between the
groups by looking at the total mean so
there are crucial issues in this in that
it is not well defined what they are  how is the
space how do I represent the problems
how is the distance calculated how many
clusters do I have some information about
the clusters that q  I want to distinguish
especially in the heads that are very, very
large
I want to need a
hierarchical structure and problems in which one
needs to see how the
different clusters come together to reach the
structure that one wants to see
how to achieve it we are looking at the
distance  because, well, one needs that
information in the phylogenetic part, one
needs to see how
each is joined, the points are species, the
points are, one needs the relationship they
have to reach the clusters, the
class number that one needs,
so one has to represent the
problems of  a special way you have to
look at them the more I know about my data the
more I will be able to interpret after I
managed to generate a partition
similarities once again it is tied to the
point of what I want from what I
know about my data my data is
discrete continuous
ordinal categoricals that are my data in the face
of with the supermarket shopping cart
or the skills of the
players  tors is to say that is what I
have to know to distinguish to
work with a metric that allows me to
say when a metric or a
similarity that allows me to say when
two things are close
then these cartoons show how
difficult it is to decide even for the
audience  when two classes when
when a cluster partition is is it
right or wrong because one can with
the simpsons characters make many
different clusters this is one of
the possible partitions that there are
measures of similarity i
'm going to go a little faster to
and  resemblances
resemblances distances and affinities are
the names given to the function
that will allow me to say when two
points are close or not because between
documents it is different from between
clients and between images and between
real estate properties the similarity
should bring out the causes
that make these two elements
close if I have a resemblance that
is not correct
maybe not  is showing me the
characteristic that would put them close
[Music]
the other thing that one sometimes has to
do is normalize or standardize the
data so that there is not a variable that
is very large that is separating the
data and it is not the separation that  I am
searching because it is the trivial one, the strip of
the trivial one, I don't care, I care
a little deeper, so if I
have very dark and very light data, it
is better that it is going to divide them into light and
dark, and I am not looking  that's what I'm
looking for the shape and the shape has the
shape and the background has light and dark
so I did standardize and remove the
light and dark and start to understand that I
have a shape and a background so there are
ways to standardize one is the
standardization towards the  0 1 the remainder
by the minimum divided by the width of the
interval and the other is the set score that
the remainder by the mean and divided by the
standard deviation then
good and the categorical data if I
have in my v  continuous and
categorical variables I have to think about how I am going to
do the codding of the categorical ones
that if it is a woman and a man I have to
decide on
a numerical data 0 and 1 I can, however
there I do not have any value the average does not
make any sense in which I am
turning it into numeric to be able to
work with it, then there are others in collings
that can become more interesting
if I have an ordinal value I need to
keep it because then there if the
order of the natural numbers allows me to give
information but when I have
loose categories in reality those
values ​​do not  do they have or do not have the mean
does not make sense usually python
when I have categorical and
continuous values ​​when I ask for
fear measures and the variance usually does not give me
those of the categorical ones because it
just does not make sense but now
if I have a column set to zeroes
and you don't realize if it's an integer you
don't realize that about the area code
or clearly the area code  ea
of ​​telephones does not make any sense the
average yes then there should be
fashions but I have to tell you well those
are simple considerations that one
has to take into account when
doing a job that has an
interpretation
so in continuous data it is very
Importantly, on the one hand, the Euclidean distance is used a lot
when I have
some sense in the module and, on the other
hand, I destroy the utility distance a bit
and transform the
distance of the cosine into the angle, which has a
relationship with the correlation, so there are
clustering methods  very very good
in which they
are made specifically for certain
data that are known to be grouped better
using the angle
precisely the module has those when
I normalized sorry standardized the
data the distance
is transformed into I only see the
angle and there I see more characteristics of
the ones that could simply look at a
large value and a small value when I
remove, for example, condition  it is about contour,
how can it be spatial, I have the
data that is in a grid,
I take the shots out of the grid inside
a bag and in and they get that
information again when I work the angle
the distance from Manhattan under the no
editing vice  they are specific for
certain data these are all the
distances of the lp manhattan euclidean
is with equal r manhattan is the one of the
taxi here the one that looks at the number
of blocks I need to get there and the one
of chevy chef looks at the maximum of the
differences in coordinates  so
these are distances that I can
change within the same algorithm
and more to the no vis in particular it is the
distance that the weight comes out the
differences of the coordinates by the
variance covariance matrix so
this is the distance that is within
the cause na  so it's a this is
a distance distance
and it's very important when measuring
data that has been produced by
probability distributions
without  However, I can have non-continuous data,
that is, clustering can be
done with non-continuous data, but there
are specific methods to do
unsupervised non-continuous data, as they
are, and well, the distances are of this
type, the number of operations
necessary to go from one  end to end
and at the station called
jasmine stay when I have the
binary numbers the number of operations
needed to get from one end to the
other
are the usual distances but the
methods are very different from the methods
we are working on that work
for variable  continuous and that are
within what is called clustering, which
is traditional and old,
this is
groupings or partitions or
unsupervised analysis for natural language data, they
are practically
another sub-area of ​​the unsupervised
specifically, they
are very interesting, they are quite
different, then  I am going to work
with these algorithms that come a
little from the side of part
d  e continuous data
generative methods
I am going to just a little bit because I
am not going to use it but I am going to comment on what it is
and what is a generative method mixture
of gauss yang admin shift grouping
by partitions that is here media is the
most used of all the
clustering algorithms and after best can which is
a method based on density that is very
classic the idea is very interesting it is
very difficult for optics and see to work
because they are one they do not want to go from base
to the next because optics is an improvement
that works better  and there are several improvements
that are working better but it is as
if one is left with when he presents an
algorithm he presents
the algorithm that created the idea let's say the
same thing happens with the hierarchical words they
detail agnes they are very old where
the 70s are very powerful organisms
birch that  they are much more modern
chameleon they are much more modern and
when you have to pass a hierarchy you go
directly to xinglin to complete the link
keys which are the c  classic and very fast
but there are things a little more advanced
that above all work with a greater
amount of data
[Music]
this is the classic figure of that
pilot whale that
now modifies a little one but in
reality it is the classic one of that color that
shows different groups of  data and how
certain algorithms can attack these
groups of data, even by modifying the
parameters, they were not built to
solve these partitions, so they do not
work well,
well, for a long time trying to have a
pointer
to see if I can succeed,
and what I want to show here is that
these two groups  of data one inside the
other, they need a method that
chains information, that is, not a
method that looks at distances in itself,
because if you do not notice that the first one is
here, if I put a view, a
center on the right side, a center on
the left side and  the distances of the
points to that center today are going to be the
minimum and it is going to split the image in two
like this and it is not going to realize it in a  absolutely
that I have two centers one inside the
other and that they are clearly different
then that is because directly as it
was created the algorithm is wrong it
cannot think like that not in a chain so
the mixture of gauss jana is done the same
with a model also of gauss  ianas and
mein schiff also just in april in
case and the best can they can do it above
all the best can because it's the one that came out
to tell us well how do I
go by distance it's going to be fine they
say probability distribution but
chaining then chain well
The point is that there has to be a
separation between the groups so that
chaining does not leave me with a single
cluster and that is the problem with fishing.
You have to continue. You don't know where to stop.
So when I have things like that it
works very well. Look how it
works.  well in the first two in the
first two
rows instead
the second row first column and
second really puts in a center and from
a point to a ce  inside and from in the other and
part then this is the central idea
of ​​what these algorithms are
so they were created what were
the hypotheses if it were a partition of
this style then this algorithm
could find it but because something has
to be put something has to be  say, to be able to
build a method that has some
consistency,
everyone is fine here because,
well, everyone is fine in
separate circles, they have no problems
and this last row is white noise, there
is nothing, so what is the only one
that says it is fine?  the only two that
say that there is nothing then min if
nothing is found and it must be there is nothing found
the rest find something in a little dot in
a stroller find something
find
when in reality there is nothing then
if they come for this for these synthetic data
these groups work well when you go to
a database in which you cannot
see anything with a large rate and
there it is as if you find that  Actually
there comes the problem of the two
visualization problems and the one of
managing to run the algorithm
mixture of guarantees. It is an algorithm that
I am going to pass because I am not going to use it
in FIFA, but it is a generative algorithm,
that is to say, I suppose that what
I have is a
probability distribution behind and that
probability distribution is a
mixture of functions that is of
Gaussian densities that I know so I have
to estimate a million parameters to
achieve it but I have a
generative model that is to say my model can
simulate data of the style  of those that I
have and what partition they have in that way
so it is a very powerful model when
I can really estimate it
so it is not useful for anything in
that data like that I need all that
amount of gaussian ianas that is two
I really need enough to be able to do it
reach and it is difficult for
classification I do it or I know for
classification I find that that is
generated by a model and  when I want to
classify I give it a label
and it finds it but for clustering it has a
hard time
well now yes
and it's healthy no more than
ninth it's google powerpoint this is a
gif
this would have been nice to see it doesn't
turn around when it starts that
's the beginning of  gif when it starts
the desire moves until it finds
the two centers in the body of
playstation maximum 6 john usually
manages to do those things
what is he doing I don't know it
was completely he
has another problem quickly I
can tell that I have to tell him
what the amount of  causes
that the mixture has and it does what it can
when it finds it when I tell it the
right amount it can find it this
was run in that heat and
the mixture really works very well when there is
little data and they
have been created for a reason I don't know
you can find the one that
automatically created this by using the bic
I did or some of the criteria that are
based on the density that  and I have
and now it insists on this I am interested in
because it is different from the gauss mixture
and nas in the sense that I
can not apply it to a very
large database because although they still
think that I have a
lot of distributions behind  of probability,
that is, I have a joint of a complex joint,
I am going to try to estimate the local density
from what the density is locally
through a kernel, so I am going to
use a non-parametric density in
a very interesting algorithm, and thus
I am going to be able to, I am not going to  having the need to
know a joint distribution that
has a plethora of parameters without
being that what I want to do is
label a group of data I am not going to
get a generative model anymore but I am going
to be able to classify also using the
idea that I have
probability distributions that  define me then
a kernel is applied which is a
weight function of a window with a
bandwidth and that is the only parameter that  I
'm going to need it because
the gif doesn't work either, but supposedly
if these are the points and that is the
density that is behind, the
mein schiff algorithm takes those
points towards the center because it
estimates the mode of each one of
those  three modes that supposedly have
that density and then it will classify
as the point closest to that mode and
the point is that if I tell him to
use a much smaller bad guy than
the one he used before, he
has that problem, he takes me to the points
more inwards and then it ends
up putting together modes of a single point
so it is very very
the bandwidth is a much
more sensitive parameter and it gives much more trouble
than it
here and there means the reason why
the k-means algorithm is really a
algorithm that is widely used
I cannot use any of the
mathematical methods that are based on density
as I know the joint density
but I can because the kernel of ansite
estimation is a  non-
parametric estimator of density and there are
theoretical bandwidths that I can
use to be able to calculate
the bandwidth from a group of data
in this slide I put how I
generated these data with gas goce a nash
I can later ask
how it says  the classification of the
partition with respect to some measures
and here we have here averages
and from there I go to 10 min shift and this is the
largest transfer that is why
I am going to cut a little to
pass the bad to python later and here averages
have  behind this idea
I have an initial partition that I do
simply by saying well I need I
want three
clusters I say that the means are these
three clusters any of the three
points I have are three the son and
then I think that by looking at what
are the closest points to  each one
of those centers grouped them and I look at
an objective function that is what is
called the inertia of the algorithm the sum
of the distances between the dist  into these
points and I am noticing myself
with this new partition at the end of the
first partition that I had in the
partition of those close to the three
points that I put, it proposes, it calculated the average
of the partition and I see if
points move and there are  points that are close to
that new partition that I made and
I change them again and they control the
inertia every time I do the iteration
I check if this new iteration
reduces the inertia and when it stops
reducing it stops
and
supposedly stops when there is no more
changes between iterations or
when the inertia is
small enough according to the tolerance that I have
set it
is an algorithm that non-
parametrically
gives me a partition of a mixture of
gauss and nas when the wins are
spherical
[Music]
is a  It's a pity that it doesn't work
well, like everything with optimization functions, it
is a bit unstable
with respect to local minima, but
modern algorithms already have several
layers to avoid the  local minima
this says a small image to
say how it works when I have
different songs that should be
optimal and the point is if they are spherical
the cause is fine if they do not have to
be extremely separated
the gauss mixture jana in these cases
is perfect
as  I do to calculate the k the inertia
is a place salt is a quantity that is
calculated because it is the objective function
therefore when I can run
the algorithm with several they see several
values ​​from here and calculate the inertia and
I make this plot that you see there  that it is a
blog as if it were an elbow when
the inertia stops going down but instead
begins to stabilize because it always
goes down when I enlarge the one that even I
can leave all the
loose dots and that will be even lower but
I can  finding that when you do an
elbow to that is an indication that that
's a decent cluster it just
found me exactly the number of the
cluster that I had created in this
example  For example, but hey, there is something
else called silhouette analysis that does
something like this, that is, I look at
all the points, I create a vaccine, an
index for each of the points, and I
look at that silhouette for each of the
groupings that  In this case, I do
two less clusters,
there is a silhouette that is very large and
has negative values, so I
can say this one, no, because you
cannot go to negative values, it is bad,
this other one also has a very
small cluster with negative values, because
I have to  do more
this one I also have too many clusters and of
course this is the one that gives me for the
clusters for the group that takes me to
prepare
, however this is not bad either and
yet it is not giant and the other one is not the
values ​​of the city silhouette are not
bad because deep down if I put together
something like that below, the
conditions of spending well grouped and
well separated are met, so
I would have to have these two groups  And
if I have a group of data that is very,
very heterogeneous with one class that
interests me and the other does not have this form,
that is, I have one thing, for
example, if they have ever worked
with loyalty to a company, the
loyalty data with  person from the telephone company they
have the people who stay
with the company is 80 percent and the
other 20 or more 85% and 15 is the one who
changes and the only interesting thing is to
understand what the people who leave are like
the company does not understand the ones that stay, it
is like the people who, but the one that
stays, have that shape, have states
inside, they are not homogeneous, it is a class that is
too large, so the partition that
matters
is what I am seeing here, so it
is not a law in clustering  no one does not have
to rule out this type of partitions
just because one of the silhouettes of
is too big one could study
a little more because there is precisely a
variable that is variable n in that
case in this type of alg  orithm in that
type sorry that type of data group
there is a variable that explains what
the loyalty variable is and that really
the reason why these algorithms are studied
the best can is the last one I want to
mark because it is the first one that started
another type of clustering study area,
one is means with
distances and centered today and the other is
minute with non-parametric density estimators
and the third is b-
scan where I also want to study
density but I want to chain because it
will work  better when I chain
then I will find high
density areas separated by low
density areas and there will be cutting elements
core points which are the points at
which they would be in the center of the cluster
and the edge points of which
From there I have to separate the different
clusters so that allows me to
separate these bulaix perfectly
so as an idea it is the first idea
that is really very good  then there are
many other algorithms that polish the
problems that it has of fishing but you have
to give credit to the one that started
the work so unfortunately nothing
but it finds me the happy face the gif
finds the face completely because it
can jump so once again this
is very very interesting
this gif is everywhere on the web but it is very
separate, that is, the big problem of you must
cannes when I have a density of
points later I am going to show them
quickly and show the soccer players
I have intense they are very centered very
close therefore this tends  to find a
single cluster here I need air in
between to be able to find the different ones
the whole face each one of the eyes the
mouth and the edge edge the face is a
different cluster besides that and one of
them is completely chained from
any of the other methods
this system finds me but good in
dense data I know they are dense but
I don't know if they are dense it is a
giant database  as I know how they are separated,
well that's him and him,
that's how these three behave, that
half my chip and you must kahn with these
groups of data that are very particular
and notice that you must kahn doing very well
with the two croissants with the bull  there
are that they are sufficiently separated
because in the chain and of course
when there is nothing there is nothing the point
is that one says how can it be that in the
can base of soccer there is nothing,
that is, it is very dense
then
[Music]
so I want to play
with python for a bit
[Music]
I put the figure
with the fifa 19 data
that seemed quite interesting to me I
picked up a notebook from khairul it has a
lot of good it puts the data every
year and from there there are a lot of
visualization notebook of some many of
visualization that is to say classification there are
some very few clusters but
the visualization ones allow at least to
learn how to manage a database without
having to pass the 20  0 hours needed
to understand what the variables are
here I have given them to my students
here so that they suffer a little and they have done
very nice things so
I downloaded the data because there are several
packages some packages are clean
of missing data and others  No, but it doesn't
make much sense to clean the
missing input data because unless
you know a column that you don't want,
for that you have to specify why,
for example, you are going to get out, that is, the
skills of the archers are completely
different from the skills of  the other
players, therefore, surely there is
missing data in columns, so it
takes out all the archers and then there is
one if it considers that there is a
column of archers that does not have the
other players, they take the players out, that
is, one drops
and takes out all the  data base and it stays with
zero so you can't go around
taking out bustamente you have to look
a bit and eliminate the columns that
belong to a certain  as categories that is
very funny
so this is it we are going to put one there is
going to be this notebook that I made that
I made based on another one that is like everything on
the web is public therefore one here
in the val goes up at least not
even  the name belongs to the person I
thank him like that the bm he I don't know who silva is he
put this and I said hey now I'm
starting to tinker
but I thank him a lot because he started
because you have to start with something you have to
start and if the bm passed  from English to
Spanish sorry from English to French
so he also got nourishment from
something else that's how we all get nourishment
so I wanted to do a tutorial
it means that one has to tell a
little bit about what he is going to do and
then show how  this is an
idea of ​​the tutorial
I am going to block with the plot li because
it allows me to move the cursor and find
all the players
the visualization is very nice and in
clusters the visualization is very important
so there are two
visualizations that  And I'm going to
do the classic ones, that is, I'm going to do
the clustering on all the data
because, well, rather, all the data
without the archers, then well, because if
it's not a huge mess, but
then I have to visualize
what  I did, that is, first I am going to
visualize the data a little to see
what the archers can really get out and
then I am going to visualize with
principal components what I gave because
I have something that in some type of
projection I have to find out a
little what it is  I'm going to do
what I got and from then on
what I could do and
above all rule out some methods that
don't work
for this group of data so
I loaded a lot of things up here a
few but  I loaded
and inter tools bands then plot link
because it's the one I'm going to use I
find it quite interesting
the cake shakes sorry you
need are or else he's born from embodies
what you say
let's see
have m  i assistant
there it
is not
fantastic
and he wanted to do me i don't know what
you see there
perfect i repeat again for the
other subject i was teaching
usually he got up i follow or matt pelot
link that reminds me in my
dear matlab but this  plot lee seemed
really cool to me, that is, when it comes to looking it
will have other resources that we need
computational resources but we really
can't look a little more
[Music]
the master's students told me
that it seems r
well it's great so we ask
ward so this is it  the one that is
downloaded now at this moment from queiles data
point csv before it was downloaded a tenth
fifa it seems to me yes
ah well then yours has another
name is good this is the data csd the one
that is now in
cairo I downloaded it now it is 18  1,207
players and sorry 238,206 players
I think the first is the name and it has
89 columns
89 variables not all the variables
refer to all the players because
there are precisely var  skills that
entel either do not have or do not have, then
we can see that there is ied and that nobody
is interested in
the name, age, photo, neither is anyone or
nationality flag overalls is the way
to cross them, let's say, as an index
of
overcoming super player
potential club ways, that is, how much does he charge
is for long periods of advice, etc.
yes yes yes I am a teacher so I
can't do these things zero well if
you want to work it's the worst thing of all
is that the database breaks me because
you have to get rid of the  strings and you have to make it
transparent after transforming it into a
number, that is, there is a lot of information in here
that has a number and a code
and therefore you have to pass it to something
else to be able to run the algorithms,
yes, and you also have to try not to look at
those  things that is very sad
very sad so I'm going to look at it like this
the first thing I did
[Music]
after this is look at the players
by position with overalls and position
so I took the data frame q  I armed
myself with pandas in a monkey position and I'm staying with
this one, which is not the best, my son yelled, and
because that is not to say, pandas will
lift if in the same category there are
several players with the same achievement for
the same position, they will lift the
first one and  the first is the first that is
how it is in the base cat not
necessarily the first because it is
better then it is going to put one in each
position then that is where the
screams of no begin but why is not such
and such in such and such a position
because he probably gets another overall he
doesn't have or
it wasn't the first on the list there is a
middle that worries me when I went
downstairs I couldn't find it middle where is it
and well it's over there but it's
supposedly the best in its category with
a 94 overall  that he is one of the
tallest if he is the tallest
Cristiano Ronaldo has the same 94 but
they put him in another position so that he
appears on the
list anyway
I am bad
one usually simplifies that is to say not to
use all the characters  istics or
simplifies a lot simplifies in one way
you can explain in another way
forward filders defenders angol keepers
well walkie it seems it is a category that
has a quarter of the things
that the others have therefore if it does not
do it if it does not separate itself it is like  It
shouldn't, that is, everything is wrong,
but it bothers me a lot when it comes to
doing a casting with it, also because it
has half the variables
that the others have, so practically
if I visualize it and see it separately, I take it out
because it is a category in itself  same the
rest at least I can use
most of the skill variables to
try to make a 'cluster' but it
reduces the amount of variables also
this is made to play this is
made to add another variable and take out
a variable and pass and  run the
algorithms to see what comes out of
armed like this and now I have these
amounts
two thousand 866 defenders 5500 forwards
four thousand six hundred
something  diocampistas and two thousand or so
archers and some that
I can't even define well
[Music]
so the first thing I want to see
is that really in this database the
archers are divided from the rest
but in such an amount of data there is
no  way to separate them, that is, I
can't look at it, I have to find some
principal component visualization, it's
one of those visualizations, but there is one
and another principal component visualization, it
's a very old mathematical method
of rotation, and but in
this data set, the first two
components  The main ones give me 50% of
the variability, just a
little bit, so I tried another
visualization that is quite heavy
but that tries
to fence for a similarity issue,
the point is that it greatly modifies the
structure of the data that is psn,
but  we can visualize highly
dimensional data the point is that I
convert the similarities into
probabilities and then that  s
probabilities measures distances in the
probabilities and in those
new distances the distance is leiber
rea's fault and just then it maps me to the two
dimensions then
they have several little details first
that make the little drawings very nice
but the similarity matrix changes with
the  that I worked so I shouldn't or should
n't do a cluster in
the visualization part, that is, it is
a visualization, one has to do a
cluster with the variables that it has, that
is, with all the players with and with a
set of variables that you choose, but not
in  the visualization not in the two
but other things not that is I have done
clusterin on the first two
main components usually that is
project and there I do the clustering and it does
not give me so bad because the project and the
projection take all the variability
me  I really reduced dimension and kept
the same structure but well
main components is a rotation
of the space and this is not this is highly
not li  neal then
but it is interesting to do it as a
visualization so this is the code
to visualize and I had to shrink
like this instead of taking the first 2000 not
all the players I worked with the
ratings and
some towards not the 80 variables
but there are variables of all
then  I told him I reduced the
[Music]
a little bit I reduced my data set a little bit
to be able to run it on my
machine so
as here we are going to cross
our fingers your machines because mine
had done quite well
but well then let's go  from now on
at least I load the data I tell him to
change from three different machines yes
so mine has a very bad screen but it
has a very good processor and a very good
memory the money was divided into that part
let's say
if it looks ugly it doesn't matter I have  a beautiful
monitor to be not to look at things
but well life is hard
the life of the teacher is very hard well
now I'm getting to this part where you
have to  and
run the csn
and
the slow one after a while so
you have to decide you ran it
sometime
so we put
no I put dominoes I didn't have 14,000
I also went to sleep and came back
and it doesn't make much sense when you
want to make a  visualization because what
I did run with many players was the one
that halfway yes then there we are where
you see that I with 2000 dressed and walked with
2000 and number of components dose of
perplexity 30 that is the other thing it
has parameters with some divine names
perplexity  it is one of those exaggeration
accumulates low due to exaggeration to a
parameter but well it has those things
but the perplexity is complex that is, it is
that one combines the perplexity lower
higher the graph changes where it is
working and the visualization is very
different you are two changes no  more but it
seems to me that I am not going to do it in the
number of matched components and the
component number is equal to 3 it cost him much
more in 3 to make the graph and he changed me
a lot of visualization instead this
visualization
should work fine
because that's what I want I want
this
and guess who these guys
are these are the walkie pers
so it's really completely
separate however I change the
parameters of tse and the walkie pers me
they put in the middle but in the middle of
the others then it is not a question of
saying if it changes a lot if there is one that you do not
know or if it is a very nice visualization
when it works but it is very complicated to
understand why it
generates a type of visualization and not of
another anyway the hits
even when they go from being extremely
separated because if in the following
visualization they are in the center but they
are compact then they really are
a cluster but none that is if I
want to send a
cluster method to that thing to a castro  all set up nothing is
going to be very difficult for me to separate very very
difficult clearly the goalkeepers
are separated from the rest of the
players  players that I have positions are the
best the 70 best those have
names and it is on the list that the
overalls have but here are all the data
that I did and all of them here are all the
goalkeepers and if I enlarged this it is in
700 by 700 but yes  one enlarges it more
then thinks it will separate a little better
and sees a little better
and here the interesting thing is that the
yellow labels are on the
firm label so there really is
a part that separates these from each
other
and this is not done with or macri  nor do they do
such a nice thing, that is, plot
li is quite reasonable when it comes to
working as a visualization
well this is the one that is a little
longer so I am going to leave
it I advise you to look at it because with three
components I change a lot  I don't have it
because it's not my machine so I didn't
have the visualization
this is another visualization that I made
but I load it to the same one, that is, it's
not loading the same one because I had to
put another name
and  this is the one with three components
that I tell you that you load them
if I don't run it that way, it's very heavy the
rest is not so heavy
now I'm going to work a little bit but
I'll go back to work with the 18,000 because
I can do these things with  the
18,000 then but I want to
choose the skill rating and look only at the ones
that are more those with a
good overall rating
and if I look at the main components
on that type of opa
if I look at the main components on
that type of file art it looks
like no  there is this there is not so much
variability explained in the first
two but it will allow me to project
well
then
well here is another of the
visualizations they say
and it does not let me look at the gray well
that
everything is fine the machine did not hook me for
some reason
well this is another  from here are the
main components that was what
the players wanted to show for the
main components and of course
there are the best 70 marked no well
if not no t  I have too
many too many letters
some even I recognize him and then
I can recognize some of the
godin caught then I can mark in the
main components where they should
be grouped by position
recognizing some other this man
who is here is also a defender
who loved the person  that here there are
others of those
then one should say well here
over here the midfield should be over here
the attack should be here which is messi that
is the million dollar question that is over
here to the side and here would be the defense
and here is a tip is  as
if you really look at the best
70 they are in this arch and then the
tips give me other players
[Music]
then with that representation
I'm going to look at the players for
two types because I can't do it for two
exchange rates I had  that for having
changed the background color
and I have this arch also where I
can see the players in that arch and
there are many more players  You pray here but
well in this arc there are players
from those two teams
where I can also recognize a little
where they would be without the goalkeepers where
the others
would be where the partition would be with
cummings
the different
ones the different positions of players
we are going to go from to  one
does not like to run now for an unknown reason
now I went from behind to the front of
someone who
is there
these are they are colored
and what happened to him that he does not like
but what a barbarity
no no there is not a
cluster 2 because it should not be called
cluster 2 by  s
I'm going to be called scumbags
that's why he doesn't like that k half and that
half
really arms me
and the different positions
quite reasonably in the sense in
which sense if I have to do one
the three that follow the three little
color graphs are half
and you must can
halfway concentrate follow the line do not
forget that I am doing this in the
space of the variables and I am
projecting but because  yes it is done that
is no no I cannot reduce the dimension
in such a way but in the space of
the variables
the first two could be projected totally
mixed and yet they follow the line
of the variables
so once again I can recognize
that with  the players that I
recognize are in the positions that would be
the central position of each of the
classes that the four-position label was used
is very, very little ring grain, that is, it
is too concentrated, I need
a little more, here I told you that  he would put 5
in mein schiff
and I tell him to do what he likes
with esteban with dedos
and he finds 13
but if you look at the 13 he
finds the colors are very close
and then he goes to another type of color and
then he goes to another type of  color is
because it really finds what are
called states within the same
plaster
because in reality the players are
divided into 20 positions, not four
or three like that  what swift me is how it
disarms
that many states a little better now if one
wants a more compact partition
halfway it gives a better partition than what
you did for me it does now when I want to
go to the best can and change it 200 times
there is no  way that it is too dense of the
space and one in only it only
finds a cluster it cannot
divide the space anymore and I varied them in everything I
did a sweep of the parameters and I
could not find a division that is
because the method is not prepared for
this  Instead, I work here, averages, well,
I have told him to do the best
possible job with five groups and he
did it with much more cohesion and mein
schiff that he only chose him when he
found the granularity that these data
have because they are precisely the
positions of the players  I
'm only using skills I could have
used equipment I could have used
countries I could have used
other things would have been quite
interesting but for  skills is the one who
supposedly has to
predict the position of the player supposedly there
are 20 variables that predict position
so for for this to close this
is to cross out the uneven
these algorithms run with large
amounts of data
they do not have that is, I would not encourage myself to be a
mixture of range of  oceans, but if these
three
are now created for various
activities, therefore, in a group of
giant data like this, they may very well
not be able to generate a
partition that is reasonable for the
problem, but it can be visualized and
the clusters that separate can be visualized first.
they separate well to be able to
first extract the information that I already
know is separated and try to divide the
information that is not separated to
see what emerges differently the
visualization is important that is why
the other thread marked as if to say if
I  I have to put a name to each
class I need some information but
that part is called semi superv  Isada
I need some information about the
players that I know he has in that
position, so I say this is the
similarity, all these players are
within the core of this group,
so that is important when it comes to
seeing how many states are coming from now on.
I want to find
out so what I should do is leave my
boss and you should work with k averages and
move here with a silhouette job to
really see how many groups you really
find in this data group and
then live to study the profiles of
the players inside  of each one of these
data
or
[Music]
this is what I wanted to present as
a start-up tutorial on caster in and
comment this is a very hard work area it
is much simpler the
classification is much simpler it is
soup there are long 2012  the boys
released about 20 being that was the work
they had to do area to release
many classifiers and study them in
this group of data and there was and the
classification  ion was very high, that is, a very
good classification for the labels
with when one gave him a
training sample here I cannot, I cannot
classify him, that is, I do not have that
rate of good classification with this one with
these groups that emerge not even with
averages here  he did not even reach 70 of the
label that he has that if I tell him what
he has to do
casey boost gives me more than 90
percent of good classification without
improving the parameters improving
bone lift so to this extent with the same
group of  data to tell you how hard and
how difficult it is to work with
clustering that emerges and that the semis
of the semi supervised looking for a
little label information is much
better it's much easier for me with
even a part of the
labels to be able to guide  the
algorithms and being able to associate the things that
I don't know to the things that I could
and cure it is called verifying that the
label was correct
well this is
the tutorial that I wanted to present and
here I am going to leave it halfway
and well thank you very much for having
listened to me and waited and armed
so that I can present this to you
[Applause]
well we have a few minutes for
questions so if someone wants to be
hello hello
I have a doubt regarding
what one uses  In general, these
unsupervised algorithms to
discover information and do not know how
the cluster is composed if we or
the clusters that we find if we
use psa and we have two components
we have to interpret the components
I understand to be able to interpret the
clusters then there are two questions one
that  methods exist to interpret
components and the other how we can
interpret a cluster that we do not know
why it is formed well
that is the art that is the very
long previous transparency ended with how
hard it is once I put together the law
in the partition because right here  I
what we have three that plot a
little we can go looking inside
each one of the  cluster the labels of
the players we know
to be able to identify well with
respect to these players these others
are similar to these players as
a quick way because the main component
is to mix all the skills
to verify it is to give that is
that idea but in reality there is  to
take pleasure
and look at the skills one by one and
start making plots of the skills to see
what the characteristics of
those players are like
this is a visualization as if to
say ah this is similar to this
then maybe it is there it is I can
raise it  and look to get the most out of it,
I can start to see what is the
structure of those data that
made them be together,
but if I am particular for
each of the data groups that you
want to work on, it is very difficult to work
without having an ultimate goal.  question
there has to be a
previous research question
like for example I want to understand
why these people are leaving d  and the company
then all I want to look at are
the different variables I want
you to tell me to see if there is someone in a
scenario that I can do something
to prevent these people from getting upset
and leaving the company I don't know
when  he studied the telekom turn what he
notices is good the people who have an
international plan calls 800 times at cost
cost you don't serve and well he must be
upset traffic there is some reason but it's
a little bit they are like little pieces because
because the percentage of
the  target, which is the class that I want to
see, so it would be more
interesting to say, well, I do the other way around. I
look at the class of those who stay and
try to make a cluster of those who
stay and look at the different
groupings to see the  consumers
who stay have whatever characteristics they
have because those who leave are very
few and it does not tell me much because they
leave are very difficult for each other
then but
artisanal yes real  artisanal mind and
maybe you will find one or two variables
that explain to you you can instead of
main components you can try to
project on those variables capable and you will
find more information
that is unfortunately the law
and unsupervised grouping and analysis is like that
any other question
hello I want to consult a  respirito well
I know of data where you have mostly
categorical variables if there is any
method or something that can be done I think
for example in demographic data where
many times they have mostly
categorical information and not continuous
for the categorical ones usually
also use that half with a
distance  different that is to work a
more discrete distance and make a
specific intelligent encoding so that
for that for categorical data and
then use when depending
on how the distribution is like
how much data you have
a kind of mixture of instead of  be
jana gauss mix multi mix  no
vials
that mixture of multi nominals allows you to
make a generative 'cluster' with a
distribution that is much more suited to
the data that you have that if you have
data well then if you have
hierarchical data use the fact that they are
hierarchical there are several you can  to be a
grouping of imagine of trees,
that is, to group when you return, the point is that
similarity, what is the similarity that
you are going to work on, that is the point, that is, it
enters very strongly there, they are not from cars, from
videos, and it will not be the distance
online  but you have to create a
similarity between these structures, around
there, the structures in the structure,
what matters then are the passengers and
some in bed, other categories and that the
proximity is completely different if
that on the one hand because then there are
other specific grouping methods
if you, for example, want to
work the shopping cart, you want to see
how when they inform cake, it wants to
find clauses, that is, it is
finding  ar things that are similar to each other
but
you have to define that type of clauses
the proximity is completely different and
the algorithms in the priori work
well to find
recommendations but it is completely
another area if I see a lot of face here
stockings but with their transmissions
indifferent with another measure
and with how the organization function
changes because the data the measure of the
mean is not a measure if it is not a
similar age and it is discrete then in the
end the algorithm also changes to
get to that point but because the
data is  very different if it is
focused on mostly continuous data
or data that has been unfair has
direct codding with natural numbers yes
thanks you're welcome
any other questions you want to ask
if the question I wanted to ask was
about what is the performance of
the algorithms are different because
several of the several that you
named I worked on at some point
and for example in what I know  n parameters
for the k averages or also the one that was the
gm itself is how it has a very
big impact when the parameters change if
not me at least in what I heard about all
this there was not much mention about how it
affects the times  of execution not
good the point
is that what I told you the
difference is how many clusters there are is the
only parameter it has and
the silhouette is what I am going to use
because you do not have another measure you do not have
many more measures unless you have
a training sample that you do not
use, that is for one thing is to use the
training sample to create the
classifier that is supervised and another
thing is to generate an automatic clustering algorithm to work
but then see
how it went with respect to the labels
that you know  So there you do have
five or six measures that are in the
transparencies narrating the faith, but you
need a sample of a training sample,
that is, you knew that
this was the case and you wanted to see
i could automatically find it for you
even if it is similar so you have
many measurements but depending on what they
measure differences in labeling put
so many points in both palermo from the
contingency matrix to more
delicate things yes so there are measurements
for that now to find the
specific parameters
the flat gauss mixture the encounters
except the one that is equivalent to say you have
to say how much you want
expectations maximization of encounter
everything that is to say that is the algorithm in the
spirit of creations in reality it is not
a cluster creation algorithm but
the same of  estimation of a plan of a
joint density by expectation maxim
and 6 jones now expectation maximization
needs one as a parameter it needs
how many for how many parts does the
mix have and there if one should use a
maximum expectation 6 john within a
loop with the weill well you see me  I
showed you in the slide that I
added not only calculates the  beige is
but simply change the keys
because that heat allows you to
tell it what type of variance covariance it
intends is because if you do it is
calculate a variance covariance to full it
is very heavy instead you can tell it
that they are all spherical and that is  how to make
a generative model of a sitcom
then you can also look at the
beige and see how it went with all those
models and choose the model that has the
least b and c for some data a
generated desire that I did I found it
perfect I found the model that I  had
generated for such dimensional data
that only half needed the k and
the one that comes out a little more from the contour, that is,
I set it to 5 because it seemed
to me that it was more than reasonable for the group
of data that I had if, by bescanó, it
needs a very  strong and I
have a hard time if there is no separation to
find and the granularity of the environment
for it
is more because it needs a minimum number of
points in the environment and a radius
for the landmark roundabout that is moving,
optics no longer asks you for the radius to
find it, it only asks you for a
minimum number of points, so
change an algorithm that already has
internal definition of the parameter is
better but
it is the only measures measured  of
quality that exist are with respect to
a classification that you have and
the rest is completely empirical and
according to what you see how you have
to study the classification
and the resulting partition
[Music]